an Indiana man who drowned while saving
his three-year-old from a sinking car
did not know the vehicle had been
recalled yet that he Burgess left this
the little girl inside the parked
pontiac g6 when it slid backward into a
pond last month in 2014 GM warned a
defect with a transmission shift cable
could cause the vehicle to roll away
police are investigating to see if that
was a factor Adriana Diaz is in
Indianapolis at the scene of the crash
Adriana good morning good morning this
view of the water was one of the things
Anthony Burgess liked about living in
this apartment complex he and his family
had moved here just three days before
the accident the car belonged to his
girlfriend who says she was never told
about a recall three-year-old Amina
Garrett is alive today because of her
father's fearlessness just over two
weeks ago Anthony Burgess pulled her out
of this car after it rolled into an icy
retention pond the 2008 Pontiac g6 was
in park but it's engine was running as
he was outside talking to a friend Kelly
Jordan isn't mean as grandaunt he just
started running and he just said I can't
swim I can't swim but he was still going
for that water he jumped in that white
without hesitation Burgess kept Amina
afloat long enough for a bystander to
grab her before he slipped under the
surface Darian Garant is a Mina's mother
she just say I was in there dirty water
with my daddy he got me out but he
didn't get out he's still in the water
2005 to 2008 Pontiac g6 s along with
Saturn auras and Chevy Malibus have been
recalled because of a transmission shift
cable that can break drivers may think
their cars in park when it really isn't
the problem affects more than 1.1
million vehicles in 2014 GM sent letters
to owners saying the company would fix
their cars for free as of July 2016 a
little more than half accepted the offer
but nearly 30 thousand owners couldn't
be reached Garret bought the car last
year three years after GM first sent the
notices she says she never got one I
think they should go to the extreme to
get every car fix
because it could cause somebody's life
about 70% of recalled cars actually got
fixed in a statement GM said owners of
older vehicles are less likely to
respond to these initiatives and there's
currently no legal requirement in the
u.s. that customers have recalled
repairs made John Major Anna thanks you
want to find out about your cargo to
safeguard gov